like if you're so body positive why do
you need to pull in the blubber be
positive put it all out there don't suck
it in in 2022 and also and she's saying
my brand isn't body positivity well you
have a shapewear line but be real body
positive sell a workout call me crazy
all right what do you do she also
launched the Emmy women Prime video
called blizzo watch out for big girls
okay so your brand isn't body positivity
but you have a show called lizzo's watch
out for big girls when Adele was big she
didn't do this and this is what we're
talking about women The Gaslight this is
a gas lighting technique she's like I am
not about body positivity but you have a
shapewear line and you had a reality
show called lizzo watch out for big
girls in which so what does she do on
the show I wonder maybe it's not about
big girls maybe it's nothing to do with
your body